à charlottetown
on installe les affiches électorales
mais on installe aussi des affiches pour
un autre vote car contrairement aux
libéraux fédéraux le premier ministre de
la province
c'est sa promesse électorale tous les
électeurs de l'île devront se prononcer
lors d'un référendum sur un changement
de mode de scrutin
le mode de scrutin est actuellement
utilisée est le même que celui utilisé
par tous pays
c'est le système uninominal à un tour
donc le candidat qui obtient le plus de
votes est élue ce que les détracteurs du
mode de scrutin actuel lui reproche
c'est justement ça de pouvoir former un
gouvernement majoritaire
même si le parti n'obtient pas une
majorité des voix par exemple en 2015
le parti libéral de justin trudeau a
obtenu près de 54 % des sièges même s'il
a obtenu moins de 40 % des votes
ces résultats donnent des munitions à
ceux qui considèrent un changement de
mode de scrutin
il ya des dangers d'un système actuel je
pense qu'ils étaient que c'est toujours
un parti ou l'autre puis on ne dit pas
si peut-être qu'ils représentent des
vues qui sont possiblement minoritaire
mais parce que ces minoritaires faudra
pas qu'ils soient pas entendus
l'alternative proposée et le système de
vote proportionnel mixte un système
utilisé entre autres en écosse en
allemagne et en nouvelle-zélande les
électeurs disposent de deux votes
le premier pour un candidat dans leur
circonscription
comme dans le système actuel ce vote
permettrait d'élire les deux tiers de
l'assemblée
l'autre vote consiste à choisir un parti
les députés issus de ce vote
représenterait le tiers de l'assemblée
ces sièges seraient destinées à combler
l'écart entre le nombre d'élus et le
pourcentage de voix obtenues il n'y
aurait pas plus de députés
c'est la taille des circonscriptions qui
augmente donc le nombre d'électeurs par
circonscription augmenterait de 40 à 60%
selon l'endroit
[Musique]
pour kelly morgan qui s'opposent au
changement finalement on se retrouverait
avec deux types de député les élus de
circonscriptions et ceux désignés par
les partis
on voit des gens qui se sent trop plus
confortable de voter pour la partie de
choix au lieu de peut-être choisir parce
qu'avoir tu attendais mais je vais pas
gaspiller mon vote je veux voter pour
quelque chose de gagner la
proportionnelle mixte donne souvent lieu
donc à des gouvernements minoritaires et
à des gouvernements de coalition dont le
cabinet est formé de membres des
différents partis
gary morgen il voit une menace pour la
démocratie
bon maintenant rigole en 2016 une
consultation populaire a permis de
sonder les prince édouardien le résultat
est en faveur d'un changement mais
seulement 36 % des résidents ont voté
une participation jugée trop faible pour
aller de l'avant
alors le gouvernement a décidé de
consulter une autre fois les insulaires
cette fois le référendum aura lieu le
jour du scrutin provincial un gage de
participation
changer le mode de scrutin pourrait
transformer la culture politique de
l'île du prince édouard dans toute
l'histoire de la province
seulement trois députés de tiers parti
ont siégé à l'assemblée législative les
gouvernements majoritaires siège en
continu depuis plus de 100 ans
la valse entre libéraux et progressistes
conservateurs pourraient bien prendre
ici elisa ferreira du canada charlotte